the Trump administration is placing new
restrictions on immigrants seeking us
asylum but some advocates say this move
I elates federal law the mandate
announced yesterday declares that anyone
crossing the southern border illegally
will be ineligible for asylum
the new rules target a caravan of
Central Americans now moving towards
that border Mireya Villarreal is near a
border crossing in Hidalgo Texas with
more on this story Maria good morning to
you well good morning you know we were
with those troops all day yesterday as
they put up this barbed wire fencing but
if you take a look over my shoulder
about 20 feet up you'll see the big
border wall which is why some locals are
questioning what exactly will this
four-foot barrier do that agents and the
wall can't in less than a week the US
military turned nearly 40 acres of
barren land in the small border town of
Dona Texas into a fully operational
military base captain Lauren Blanton
helps run it so really what it takes is
a lot of teamwork to make something like
this run more than 600 soldiers staff
the base set up by the Trump
administration to support Customs and
Border Protection agents in the middle
of this military base are sort of a
makeshift parking lot that's been
created for the dozens of military
vehicles that you can see right here
next to me right now we have a bunch of
cargo trucks Humvees anything that can
go out into the rural parts of the Rio
Grande Valley and from what we know more
are still coming the camp is a fortress
it kept with massive housing tents and
endless yards of barbed wire fence I'm
five two and this is about as tall as I
stand I mean is it supposed to stop
somebody or is it just supposed to slow
them down so it's a person feed their
movement and it's supposed to halt them
it also features a fully functioning
hospital first lieutenant Lida Mackey
Langan says the hospital can hold up to
four trauma patients but could be
expanded so I have four physicians
that's more than an urgent care
sometimes in part the personnel Keir are
preparing for a migrant caravan expected
to arrive at the border before year's
end it consists of roughly 5,000 asylum
seekers from Central American countries
Republicans want strong borders no crime
no chaos and no caravans critics accused
President Trump of using the military
move as a political stunt when they hear
things like it's a stunt I mean that
matters to these guys that matters I
mean if it matters to the American
citizens we are too and so the same way
we ask every informed citizen to go and
do research ask questions listen to
what's going on and then have a real
conversation we asked our soldiers to do
that as well more than 5,600 troops
right now are along the us-mexico border
2,800 of them right here in Texas you
know every soldier that I spoke to
yesterday I asked them how long will you
guys be here every one of them said
until the mission is done ma'am Nora
that's what they say ma'am today you've
done some incredible reporting thank you